welcome back to rockstars i'm eric voss
and the first episode of marvel studios
what if presents a branch in the
multiverse with an alternate take on
captain america the first avenger but
one constant among these universes is
the tesseract which plays a critical new
role in this episode that actually tells
us a lot about how marvel plans to
chronicle its early history in upcoming
titles i'm going to dive deeper into
what i consider to be the most
interesting easter egg from this episode
and try to clear up some questions you
might have had about how the space stone
functioned like why a teleportation door
opened a gateway through time in
calamari dimensions for anyone who might
have misinterpreted loki to think that
the mcu was saying all infinity stones
are paperweights now and we don't need
to worry about them anymore
hold on nope that was only referring to
variant carbon copy versions of infinity
stones that were confiscated as evidence
inside of the tva not the original
infinity stones that still exist on
their destined historical path on the
sacred timeline those are important as
ever because that infinity saga history
still happened and still needed the
infinity stones to do it it's just like
how loki variant l1130 may have been
displaced from the sacred timeline but
there was still an original loki moving
forward in normal mcu history in the
case of what if episode 1 captain carter
may exist in a separate universe but the
tesseract and space stone inside of that
universe are just as dangerous to all of
them and just as important to whatever
historical choices they make now in my
breakdown of this episode i pointed out
this italian textbook that howard stark
opens to explain the tesseract's power
and i translated the caption beneath it
to the tesseract is the true form of the
space stone which is a really big deal
for the drafters of this textbook to
know like when captain america howard
stark project pegasus the avengers they
were all trading possession of the
tesseract throughout mcu history they
gave no indication that they knew it
contained an infinity stone or even that
they knew what infinity stones were
until thor explained to the avengers and
age of ultron in 2015 and then when
thanos cracked open the tesseract in
2018. but the fact that this textbook is
italian led me to speculate that it
could be derived from the other past
italian scholarly text of the book of
cagliostro from the sorcerer's camartage
library a book that contained pages on
the time stone in the aya bagamoto so
based on that could represent a group of
people who know about infinity stones on
earth but when you look deeper at this
textbook page and you translate all the
italian texts visible on it an even more
interesting historical context around
the tesseract emerges now the italian
translation is kind of all over the
place honestly it seems like someone
might have put it in an online
translator and then threw it into the
animation but a few things are worth
mentioning the first paragraph ends
hilariously with do not let the angry
purple guy touch this obviously a
warning to keep it away from thanos it
might have just been a joke thrown in by
the animators because it doesn't really
match the professorial textbook tone of
the rest of it and then at the start of
the second paragraph under the
illustration there's the words i love
you aleah maybe a message from one of
the animators to a loved one now i like
to drink wine but i'm no expert
sommelier but for advice on which wine i
should drink and how they should be
served i lean on our friends at bright
sellers and thanks to bright sellers for
sponsoring today's video brightsellers
uses a quiz to determine your taste
preferences and then they show you a
list of the top six wines you're most
likely to enjoy from around the world if
you'd like your recommendations and want
to try them they'll ship them straight
to your door they educate you about wine
along the way with their included cards
that have helpful info like tasting
notes and serving temperatures so i am
currently on my fifth box from
brightsellers and based on my feedback
they have been sending me wines that i
really like and i've been learning more
about along the way
this is a new one check it out this is
vanishing act it's a pinot noir from
2020 william at valley and the serving
card says it's a classic organ pinot
noir this wine is fruit board well
balanced with a medium body and silky
tannins aroma is a strawberry cherry
fresh mushroom cedar on the finish i
like those flavors even tells you on a
little map where it comes from i like
that part of oregon and bright sellers
is giving our followers 50 off their six
bottle box that's a great deal so follow
the link to take their quiz and get
started or use the qr code but it's also
possible that within the mcu's history
the drafters of this textbook knew about
the mad titan and his lineage to the
eternals and the celestials the other
ancient cosmic figures that visited
earth because further down in the second
paragraph it starts talking about how
ancient civilizations recognized the
life cycle of earth and traced back
their ancestry and in doing so realized
the differing courses of the stars and
their paths across the night sky and
that there might have been some ruler of
those heavens a ruler they describe as
celestial whose kingdom they don't know
the location of now of course this
chapter is on the tesseract and it's
labeled with these norse runes which i
initially thought was gibberish but
wordcraft on instagram was able to
translate these into the runic
characters swolio perthro and suz kenaz
manas and then swoleo tiwas othala
nauthas and manas and if you were to
assume they put in manas instead of ewas
e for stylistic reasons it seems like a
rough attempt at the words space stone
now if you assume this is an italian
scholarly work about the ancient norse
peoples and their relationship with the
asgardians the people who possess the
tesseract for nearly a thousand years
this chapter could be telling the story
of the people involved in the battle of
turnsburg in 965 a.d that was in the
prologue of the movie thor when odin led
the asgardians to victory over lauffy
and the frost giants this is when odin
took infant loki as his ward and around
the time odin brought the tesseract to
turnsburg to have it hidden in this
church odin could be that ruler of the
stars described in this paragraph asgard
could be his kingdom and thanos or
threats like him could be the reason
odin hid the tesseract on earth because
we already know from the timeline that
the reason thanos waited to make his
move was odin first had to die that
death was a watershed moment that
changed everything across the universe
it allowed hella to return and it freed
thanos to be able to attack xandar to
steal the power stone which then led to
the rest of his stone quest now our
marvel family tree breakdown explained
how both thanos and the asgardians were
linked to celestial origins specifically
how thanos's father alars left earth
after a civil war with his brother zares
father to the eternal thena and elars
relocated to titan where thanos was born
as an eternal with a deviant gene
meanwhile odin and the asgardians were
created by the celestials as demigods in
a specific celestial mutation cycle so
that the asgardians take on the names
and characteristics imprinted by those
who believe in him in this case the
ancient norse people of midgard that the
asgardians fought for and now this
textbook is giving us some context of
this cosmic history from the perspective
of the people of ancient norway and then
later transcribed by these italian
scholars but also notice the detail of
these people deifying the earth and
naming it which in latin-based italian
is terra the name galactic sources like
the cree in xandar ego the ravagers all
call earth their word for it is terra
and that could have been derived from
odin's link with these earth-based latin
texts but the other deeper context we
now learned about the tesseract was red
skull's obsession with it which in this
what if episode went beyond the
live-action red skull in the first cap
film comparatively the tonsberg wood
carving is much bigger and it contains
his wooden engraving of the tesseract in
the middle of a portal with tentacles
emerging from it and rather than just
wanting the tesseract to power weapons
for hydra to take over the world now red
skull wants to summon an
inter-dimensional champion from beyond
space and beyond time now the space
stone is supposed to only open portals
in space like allowing instant
teleportation anywhere similar to the
bifrost but one thing we are learning is
that between timelines within the
multiverse there's a kind of buffer zone
that is beyond space and time referred
to as dimensions or realms like the dark
dimension the quantum realm since
ant-man was able to use pymtek to access
the quantum realm via spatial
manipulation there wasn't really any
further magic beyond that this would
mean the ultimate master over space
allows instant portal access to those
dimensions that's just beyond our
universal barrier and that would include
whatever dimension this tentacle beast
comes from and that dimension which
exists beyond time is how captain carter
time dilated 68 years into the future
similar to how scott lang in the quantum
realm accidentally slipped into one of
the time vortexes in there and jumped
ahead five years ultimately this episode
of what if proved that there is still so
much history left to uncover surrounding
these infinity stones in terms of who
bore them who knew about them and what
that led those characters to do in a few
days i'll be back to break down episode
2 of what if and i'm so excited to learn
more stuff about the cosmic side of this
marvel cinematic multiverse you can
support new rock stars by checking out
our merch options at new
rockstarsmerch.com follow me on
instagram and twitter at ea boss follow
and subscribe to the rockstars thanks
for watching bye
[Music]
you